et figurez-vous qu'il en est cet été je
le dis voilà on a failli se faire
attaquer
par des méchants
qui voulaient s'introduire dans ma
maison
[Musique]
vrai ou pas remboursement de la Sécurité
et là j'ai dit
[Applaudissements]
je vous jure exactement
c'est qu'il a tendance à tout mettre
dans sa chambre dire les objets pour se
défendre son nom et d'oublier les autres
[Applaudissements]
les mecs on regarde des vidéos on voit
les mecs armés déterminer en cagoule
c'est du chant ma chambre j'ai un simple
tu vas raconter le réseau quand j'ai
plus
un soir moi je suis dans ma chambre et
moi dans ma chambre je suis en bunker ça
veut dire les gars je suis premier adore
il faut pas rentrer dans ma chambre les
gars je te dis
et donc il y a ce fou qui tape à ma
porte à quelle heure 3h du matin 3h du
matin j'entends quelqu'un qui tape un
enfant là vous tirez
je rigole
jamais jamais on discute d'abord que
voulez-vous
et là je vois que c'est lui à travers la
porte
du réseau toi
le réseau je fais non mais il est
sérieux je rigole pas est-ce que tu as
du réseau parce que moi j'ai plus de
réseau ça se trouve ils ont mis des
routeurs dans la résidence on va se
faire canarder comme des chiens et moi
j'ai qu'une preuve à rideau il me dit
oui c'est bon j'ai du réseau j'ai eu mon
valeur bonne nuit et là il entend de
loin mais il est tard va te faire [ __ ]
parce que moi je vais pour m'endormir et
j'ai plus de trait j'ai plus rien c'est
pas Edge c'est pas 3G et lui il est loin
de moi et moi je suis en bas
non c'est pas ça
il est là
monter
Cyril à vol d'oiseau votre choix
il y a des chambres en bas il y a des
chambres au premier
âge
et moi je vois mon téléphone n'est pas
de réseau rien que des traits j'enlève
ma puce ma puce genre je travaille chez
SFR oui et je remets la puce dedans la
parole s'il y a pas de réseau ça veut
dire ils ont mis des routeurs ils nous
attaquent ce soir et je regarde comment
je suis équipé niveau qui a acheté
je regarde
j'ai la peur qui monte et je suis venu
frapper et il voulait venir dormir à
côté de moi
il fallait dormir devant sa chambre
avec qui il y avait qui on sait pas on
essaie de rentrer personne ne sont pas
partis mais vous allez y penser
franchement c'est pas ce que c'est on
était en plan Vigipirate je m'étais mis
dans ce bail tu vois vraiment j'étais
dans un bail il m'a vu j'étais ça y est
tu vois j'étais possédé j'ai dit ça y
est c'est une mission quand même hyper
serein quand même j'ai dit on va pas à
moi les Diego et tous les mecs qui sont
avec vous justement
c'était vraiment une cada parce que il y
a énormément de gens il y avait des gens
dans la maison qui s'occupent un petit
peu de énormément
et donc là il y a mon chef de sécu qui
va me voir
et là on s'est réuni dans une pièce et
là je leur ai dit l'heure est grave
parce que ça fout la trouille
des consignes de données tous les stores
toutes les portes quand il y en a un qui
est rentré faut faire le tour de la
maison le dernier qui rentre il doit
fermer j'ai mis un mec j'ai mis un mec
sur un mirador
j'ai mis de la lumière partout je vous
jure que c'est vrai et vous avez pas
fait la police non non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas mis un mec sur un mirador
il est tombé mais il est tombé sur
[Applaudissements]
je vois je vois un peu dans la sécurité
je crois que ça court de partout et
comme moi qu'est-ce qui se passe
dites-moi non rien rien
mais rien ne t'inquiète pas et après
j'ai appris deux trois jours après qu'en
fait le gars était tombé heureusement il
est jeune la force de l'âge il s'est
relevé heureusement gilbertez
à des vacances
je t'ai trouvé super zen
parce qu'au début moi je mets les mecs
moi aussi on m'a déjà attaqué c'est déjà
arrivé on m'a déjà provoqué
son téléphone avec les mecs déterminés
qui viennent au contact avec les agents
de sécu j'ai regardé sur Air France les
premiers vols
la piscine les îles de beauté c'est bien
beau mais bon moi si je peux me barrer
je me barre
quand même parano
est éclairée tu vois tous les agents de
sécurité
renforcement de sécurité tu es obligé
d'attendre que la grille pour avancer
que tu regardes si tu es pas suivi pour
rentrer chez tout ce serait parti et non
mais là en plus défendre
sont des consignes de sécurité très
simple le petit liner une calage
le moindre bruit tu dis il y a salle de
bain ils sont en train de passer par la
salle de bain donc tu travailles tu vas
voir tu attends j'ai un simple non il y
avait une salle de bain dans ma chambre
ma gâté il m'a donné une salle de bain
une chambre
là c'est fini c'est fini tu te caches
dans le placard pour rien pendant une
heure
j'avais un gros truc
c'est que j'aime bien faire j'aime bien
faire des ronds de la nuit en slip c'est
bon ou pas avec un sac à dos je vous
jure que j'ai regardé avec un sac à dos
et ils ne savent jamais ce qu'il y a
dans mon sac à dos donc je suis en slip
en train de tourner dans la maison de
poche
imaginons vous tombez nez avec un des
types qui est cagoulé etc avec un sac à
dos vous faites quoi
déjà le gars va dire est tellement
chelou quand même hein
si je vous dis la vérité même on le dit
tout j'étais pas vraiment
slipse
là du coup c'est une arme de frappe
et lui en pleine nuit me croise en sac à
dos à poil
que tu pars tu pars en randonnée
[Rires]
[Musique]
il y a des mines dans votre jardin ou
pas non la vérité franchement je pense
sincèrement et c'est ce qui est fou je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'est que le
lendemain ou le surlendemain dans le
journal Kyle m'a marqué à quelques pas
de chez nous cambriolage dans une maison
dans une autre maison ils sont dit à mon
avis celle-là c'est pas la bonne
c'est pas la bonne question
c'est chez lui c'est pas à quelques pas
de chez nous tu as dit mais c'est chez
toi de chez toi
des coproprié
53650 kalachtikov ils ont fait du tout
on avait on était comme ça en train de
te voilà des pistolets nerfs non mais je
te jure non non mais tu es fou quoi
attends
je donne pas cher de ton corps
[Rires]
je te le dis je donne pas cher de ton
corps
vous avez une micro-ondes par contre
[Applaudissements]
non voilà bien entendu les chéris voilà
on a c'est vrai
et voilà c'est ce qu'on va c'est ce
qu'on a fait après voilà et après voilà
tout est rentré dans l'ordre mais c'est
vrai que voilà c'est ça ça fout les
boules pour les autres personnes
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai